how's it going bros my name is lantern
ami peel back hop ad hired a just my
conscience
that's Jeff Fleur nuts Tina that's Ruben
that's I don't even know those two
actually to be out quite Harnish anyway
we got a lantern I guess we have to lens
not ye um so yeah welcome back to the
machine the machine is for a this is a
cannon I think at least listen hey it's
a cannon holy [ __ ] that's awesome a
cogwheel cannon cogwheel cannon made
back beautify actually I didn't make
that I lie I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
don't judge me doom at us pity it's been
a while it's been a damn long time Oh
what is going on Jesus Christ did you
bring that thing with you I come by I'm
disappointed at you you always come with
trouble but is this place okay good you
can refill your oil
alright I'll do that follow then I want
to shoot the cannon alright I wanna
shoot Kanan okay fine you can shoot the
freaking cannon but first you need to do
other things I think I'm just guessing
I'm not a pole or anything but barrels
are you these are they mutating the
[ __ ] barrels I moved it that lot rock
looks very tough what what is he talking
about did you say that yeah I did what
are you talking about this rock I'm
gonna put you down here for a while
Savannah okay fine
leave me for WordGirl what a pity I love
you I'm Jennifer I love you I love you I
love --boom boom boom gotta get-get boom
boom boom boom boom
hey I've been in here handle it this ah
ah
but yeah but nothing happening what are
you doing no no don't put me in no no I
don't even fit that's have any funny I
don't trust you and mm trust that was a
nice room that's a damn fine hey brah
you stuck
this guy's got a problem he's stuck I
don't wanna know how this happened is
save him hey what is this powder cool
but yeah Wow
you okay brah you okay there what is
[ __ ] why - hey hey alright Jesus let's
sound in the closet
is that you Jesus are you than this ha
ha what I do is rather than do anything
huh okay yeah no problemo ah
status' what happened what happened
where's the father
Billy help me I'm in here
hey Caramba what happened to father yeah
you have no idea what happened I don't
even I was too drunk to remember but it
was five seconds ago
don't question me alright fine I'm just
guessing right here that we're gonna use
this gun patty on this singular
ding-a-ling I don't even know cannon I
guess jump and then I'm gonna pull this
[ __ ] I need ammo
alright there's only one thing I want to
get rid of more than anything shoot out
of a cannon so here we go
this would have been badass look at that
look at that boom
you did alright I hate barrels I wonder
if you can shoot stuff on that pivot are
you kidding me I hate you it's not funny
I I guess we got to use the any fur
flappity I love you wait what are you
doing buddy
no no here they all are you are you
doing this to me
peel it say you're not a [ __ ] yeah no
no let's go so far
high five Peter that was freaking
awesome I can't high five but I have a
sword five you want a sword fight this
is a prophecy
let's brofist I would if I could
Charlotte that's where I would if I
could
ah Jesus Christ always at me in the
walls every single Thais knock me up I
can remember I'm silly oh no no I'm not
oh really get yourself together be a
[ __ ] man for once alright okay
all this for you oh no all right which
way I don't even know
everyone is certain deaf and the other
one is like ah what are you die just put
me down
Jesus Christ alright fine fine I guess
all adieu lid off king kelana cough
cough alone a binky bond overly dual it
off okay I guess this way alright Jesus
Christ I have such a freaking headache
right Napa day you have no idea mama oh
jeez I'm not even gonna bother anymore
like fine
hey what is this it's water hey you need
a bathroom I don't even pick up all
right let's just get blah blah blah yeah
ain't nearly drown because I'm really
getting into the final thing today
hey hey no cool in case assembly failure
I prepare proper action ritual to finish
the demon I'm not sure of this work show
a be careful one thing you love and a
pure evil and would be a black dildo a
jar full of blood and an emerald I just
say all the things you bag at around
samurai girl must be get around the may
have two things inside the round marks
and the rest inside the pentagram marks
when everything on plays exorcist he
must be religious and / alright mr.
Powell mr. Paul Rodin is that you are
you mr. Powell you don't look very happy
mr. Powell but now look at the situation
mr. Sher you're drowning ah painting
hi I'm glad you're here put me to safety
I got your booty I got you sheriff Hank
okay uh we're just gonna go are you
gonna own oh oh oh
run run better that open doors like a
mouse open doors like a mouse we're good
we're good
no problema okay don't listen to him
it's not your wife honey Nina is she oh
you like it i net i $5 holy [ __ ] it's
all Jesus Christ I've got a good to
throw him up and open the door I didn't
really work out oh man
a lot of people are like I don't
understand where you would sacrifice
himself
I mean Stefano we're talking about holy
[ __ ] I'm starting back here
how long have recorded eight minutes
[ __ ] the thing is I have a community
event tonight gross and I'm playing
they're waiting for me I'm 35 minutes
late so I actually have to end it here
hope you boys enjoyed subscribe black
favor on account stuff and I'll see you
tomorrow bye okay Brad it's okay okay
it's a deal
mm-hmm I need you here yes there we go
giving care company all right
Ravin door handle and shake it shake it
shake shake shake shake all right we are
gonna do